Tony Hawk here after it was revealed on
the masked singer last night that he was
the elephant I had no idea you were a
singer I didn't either actually
[Music]
I always wondered if I was capable of it
and when they invited me to do it I
thought well that would be a good way to
try because I am literally disguised did
your children figure out it was you on
the mast singer we have three boys in
college they did not know what was their
reaction what really you can we talk
about one of my favorite tweets from the
Oscars this year I'm just gonna read it
to you hey there's a guy who looks just
like Tony Hawk at the Oscars well so
that's that's actually kind of a play on
this meme because a lot of times I get
semi recognized or miss recognized yeah
especially because like my ID says
Anthony Hawk so people see it they're
like that you look like that guy Tony
Hawk but that's not you I was there
promoting the movie about skater Stan
called learning skateboard in a war zone
if you're a girl and it won mm-hmm and
so what we found out at that moment is
if you're holding an Oscar in your car
you get into the Vanity Fair party
everybody everybody in the car
so our car was over full of people
literally sitting on top of each other
squished and we just sucked the Oscar
out the window and they let us through
pretty cool being here with you Tony
thank you hey keep saying it I mean I
don't know about that keep singing
[Music]